New York City police say a 14 year old
suspected in the murder of college
student Tessa majors is free for now
after questioning majors was stabbed to
death in a park near Barnard College
earlier this month police say the 14
year old had been missing for nearly a
week after running off before he could
be interviewed mullah Liang he is
covering this case that has shaken New
Yorkers according to investigators the
14 year old boy is still considered a
suspect in Tessa majors murder on
December 11th in Morningside Park the
teen arrived at an NYPD precinct on
Thursday with his attorney he was
questioned and released CBS News law
enforcement and security analyst Paul
violist says if the teen does not
cooperate detectives will have to keep
digging this is going to take time for
the police department and the DA's
office to collect whatever evidence they
can majors was stabbed multiple times
during an attempted robbery she made her
way up the steps of the park to a nearby
columbia university security guard shack
but it was too late a 13 year old
suspect has already been charged in the
case police say during questioning
without a lawyer but with his uncle in
the room he admitted to being there for
the murder he allegedly told
investigators he and two friends tried
to rob majors and the other teens
stabbed her we have three juveniles we
have to make sure that this is not tried
in the court of public opinion the case
has some parallels to the 1989 attack of
a jogger in Central Park where five teen
boys were questioned wrongfully charged
and convicted violist says the NYPD is
now less likely to rush to judgment and
will do their due diligence to ensure
they have the right suspects I'm sure
that the Manhattan DA's office is going
to hover over this and the police
department is going to be very very
careful about what they do going forward
as you can see behind me by the
makeshift memorial tessa majors still
being remember here at the park where
she was murdered
meanwhile the thirteen-year-old boy has
been charged with murder robbery and
criminal possession of a weapon he is
due back in court next week jurika on
January 2nd all right well the language
for us thank you
you